-Welcome back, everybody.
If you love seeing
new inventions
and you love brilliant kids,
then you're really going to
love this.
It is time for "Fallonventions."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to Fallonventions,
Jimmy Fallon's
night of invention.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, I love inventions
and I'm okay with kids.
So we found some of the best
and brightest kids out there,
and I think you're
going to be amazed
at what they came up with.
So, let's meet
our first inventor.
[ Drumroll
Come on over, Bekah.
Hey.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you. Nice to see you.
Yeah.
You want to give me those, too?
Bekah, how old are you?
-I'm 9 and I'm from
Boston, Massachusetts.
-Hey!
From Boston, Massachusetts.
I'm so happy you're here.
Is this your invention?
What is your invention?
-This is my invention,
and I call it
The Mighty Suction Holders.
-The Mighty Suction Holders.
Okay. And, now, what does it do?
-My younger brother
used to stand up on the chairs
and tip the chairs so that
he would fall over and get hurt.
And in church,
we're learning that God wants us
to use our talents
to help other people,
so I made this invention
to help younger kids
from falling over
in their chairs.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We have a chair right here,
so we can see how
this invention works.
Can I help you with this?
So, this is the chair here.
So, your brother would stand
on this and fall over.
-Yes.
-Yeah, we can't have that.
Alright, come on.
Let's fix this.
Alright, here we go.
Roots, can I get some
suction-cup-leg music?
♪♪
Is there a theme for -- Alright.
Yeah, am I doing it right?
-Yeah.
-Bekah, thank you.
That's correct.
That's it, right? Good?
Does that feel good?
Alright, here we go.
Let me try it out.
[ Drumroll ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
That's what I'm talking about.
That is a great invention.
Thank you so much.
That is a really good invention.
Oh, Bekah, do you want to see
an invention I made?
-Yes.
-Okay, cool.
I have an invention.
This is cool.
I think you're
going to like this.
Alright, this is called --
This is --
You ever have a conversation
with your buddy at school
and you wish
you had more privacy?
Yeah?
Well, now you can totally get
all the privacy you want.
They're called
Private Chat Helmets, okay?
And they let you have
a totally private conversation
wherever you are, right?
Check this out.
It's very easy to put on.
Do you want to try it on?
Hey, Bekah.
-Yes?
-You're from Boston, right?
-Yes.
-What's your go-to order
at Dunkin'?
-My parents would prefer
Starbucks.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Let's meet our
next inventor, Liana.
Liana, come on over.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
Sorry.
[ Grunts ]
Gosh. Man, oh, man.
I don't know what her brother
is doing on these chairs.
Liana.
-Hi.
-Hi. Welcome.
Thank you for being here.
Where are you from?
-Fairfield, Connecticut.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What is your invention?
-The Zero Mess Tray.
-What is it called?
Oh, maybe I'll bring that
chair back in, actually.
Alright, perfect.
The Zero Mess Tray.
And can I try it on?
I think I know how this goes.
-Zero-mess, so, I'm --
Is it for eating or just for --
-It's to prevent messes
on the go.
-Yeah, so you're on the go.
You don't know when
it might get messy.
-Yeah.
-You throw this on.
And this rolls in.
This all fits in together?
-Mm-hmm.
-Okay, cool.
What can I have here
that's messy?
Yeah. Thank you so much.
So, I eat this mess.
Someone gives me a taco,
I'm like, "Dude, let's go.
What's up?"
[ Cheers and applause ]
Right?
-Yeah.
-Go like this.
Push it in there?
-Uh-huh.
-You take it off?
-Take it off.
-Yeah, that's what
I'm talking about.
There's your mess, right there.
Look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is good.
Liana, let me show you
an invention I had here.
This is perfect for
The Zero Mess Tray.
Oh -- Oh, yeah,
thank you so much.
Check this out, right?
So, you're just
hanging out, right?
Gosh. Oh, here you go.
[ Laughter ]
That's how I put my ties on --
all Velcro.
So, I'm hanging out, right?
We're hanging out.
We're having a good time, right?
I'm eating tacos.
You're hanging out.
I go, "Yeah,
you got any hot sauce?"
-Uh, no.
-Yeah, you don't. Yeah.
No problem. I've got it handled.
You take normal -- It looks
normal, this tie, right?
-Mm-hmm.
-No.
Check out this.
You flip this switch here.
Look at that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Put that there.
you close this nozzle here,
and then you have
all the hot sauce you want.
And make all the mess.
You like it?
-Yeah, I love it.
-Hot.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Alright, thank you
for coming on, Liana.
I appreciate it.
This is fantastic.
And not a mess on me.
This is amazing. Thank you.
Be careful.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Let's meet our last inventor.
Come on over, Remi.
Come on over here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Remi, welcome to the show.
How old are you
and where are you from?
-I'm 10 years old and I'm from
Torrance, California.
-Hey, come on!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm so happy. 10 years --
And what is
your invention here, Remi?
-Well, I invented Rubbie Blinds.
-Rubbie -- What is it?
-Rubbie Blinds.
-Yes.
-Okay, what is Rubbie Blinds?
-well, so, I have a cat,
and it always, like,
breaks our blinds.
So, the way it works is, like --
So, let's say, like,
the cat's inside,
and it wants to come out.
If it bends the blinds,
then comes out --
-So, you have no windows
in the glass?
You just --
-Yeah, exactly.
-Yeah. You like fresh air
in the house,
but you also want your privacy.
So you leave the windows open,
you get Rubbie Blinds.
Don't look in here.
And then your cat sneaks
in and out of that one up there?
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-And then you can just, like,
fix it by bending them back.
-What's the cat's name?
-My cat or this cat?
-Hmm. That's a good question.
I'm going to say this cat.
-This is Midnight Jr.
-Oh!
And Midnight Jr. comes
in through this thing, right?
And he gets stuck in
the blinds, like that.
And you go, "No, Midnight Jr."
And he's a bad -- "Midnight Jr.,
no coming into the house.
You have to stay out tonight."
And he goes out.
And this is based on
your real cat?
-Yeah.
-What's your real cat's name?
-Midnight.
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Unbelievable.
That's a great --
I like Rubbie Blinds.
Guys, can we get all
the kid inventors out here?
This is fantastic.
Here's Midnight Jr.
We here at "The Tonight Show"
love supporting
smart, talented kids like you.
We want to help you keep
exploring and creating
and changing the world,
so we're giving each of you
$5,000 to help further
your education.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Giant check.
Here, Rebekah, that's a giant --
-Thank you.
-There you go.
Liana, that's for you.
-Thank you.
Here you go, Remi.
That's for you and Midnight Jr.
That's what I'm talking about.
Thanks to Bekah, Liana,
and Remi.
Stick around.
We'll be right with
Kerry Washington, everybody.
That was great!